on peut dire que ce quatrième traitement
les minots thérapie fait ses premiers
pas cette archive date de 1967
l'immunothérapie aujourd'hui considérée
comme révolutionnaire intéressait déjà
les chercheurs
ce traitement consiste à stimuler les
défenses immunitaires du malade contre
les cellules cancéreuses
à l'époque il n'en est qu'au stade
expérimental
la chimiothérapie restait encore comme
l'un des moyens les plus efficaces pour
soigner un cancer au moyen de cette
technique qu'on appelle l'immunothérapie
on peut aider l'organisme se débarrasser
des cellules cancéreuses mais il ne peut
s'en débarrasser que d'une petite
quantité c'est la raison pour laquelle
l'immunothérapie ne peut guère être
appliquées qu après une chimiothérapie
ou associé à une chimiothérapie
en plus de ne pas être assez puissante
pour éliminer le cancer
l'immunothérapie présenter des effets
secondaires lourds comme de la fatigue
des nausées ou des problèmes cutanés
il faut attendre le début des années
2000 pour que le traitement soit plus
supportable dernier point qui est
certainement à mes yeux le plus
important c'est qu'il n'y a aucun effet
secondaire je n'ai pas eu de fatigue je
n'ai pas eu de problème secondaire
suite à ce vaccin si certains patients
bénéficient d'un essai clinique
d'autres au contraire doit mettre la
main à la poche certains traitements
coûtent jusqu'à 100000 euros par an une
situation dénoncée par la ligue contre
le cancer en 2015
les nouveaux médicaments qui
correspondent à ces avancées ont des
prix qui sont fixés pas du tout en
fonction d'une évaluation juste du coût
de la recherche de la rentabilisation
d'un juste bénéfices mais un peu dans
une négociation où entrent en ligne de
compte la solvabilité du pays avec
lequel on négocie aujourd'hui
l'immunothérapie et plus facilement
accessible pour les malades du cancer en
france
luck et rude à traitement de référence
est remboursé par l'assurance maladie
dans quatre cas le cancer du poumon et
de la vessie le mélanome ainsi que le
lymphome de hodgkin
[Musique]